all right we're back yeah crap [ __ ]
crazy man
hopefully this [ __ ] doesn't happen i'm
trying just trying to get through the
[ __ ]
suspects man i know and i have no idea
what it is
um the computer seems to be fine
connection's good
i have no idea what it is oh [ __ ] it
looked back there and got down lasers
and [ __ ] i didn't realize it went that
far back
it's like a damn nightclub in here right
i know [ __ ] awesome spots there
dancing yeah i mean
dance with [ __ ] go dance go dance
with me
do it do it yeah you got to do it look
oh my goodness
you know i love you spock you saw it
here first
i was hoping you would do like some
[ __ ] humping up against them
[Music]
okay so like i'm not sure where i was
when i cut off
everybody says that their shit's [ __ ]
up too anyway
the internet has gotten too large it's
too big it can't
handle it it can't handle like six
billion people
200 at once too many [ __ ] hockeys on
the internet
all at one time do you think that's what
the problem is yeah yeah i know exactly
too many monkeys too many [ __ ]
honkies on a goddamn internet
all right let's see if everybody's here
ready that that's a new
that's a new shirt right there too many
yeah he's on the [ __ ] internet
right it's real with the ruining errors
honkies ruin everything
yeah especially in regards to the
[ __ ]
yeah zach says my internet's been slow
so i don't know it it just doesn't seem
to make any sense to me it's just
i don't know like i said it's sometimes
we can get through the full [ __ ] show
like four hours and it's fine and then
sometimes we're streaming
like a [ __ ] weekday afternoon at
[ __ ] 3 p.m and
it cuts off after 20 minutes i don't
know i don't know it's it's great we're
going to take this
check on both the cats pookies out on
the back in the neighbor's yard hiding
behind the tree looking at me
i hit it with the flashlight and just
saw the eyes and the collar
and left baiser's out the front beijing
sitting in the
damn driveway she's just like she's all
down there she likes to sit on them yeah
in the driveway she doesn't like she
doesn't they don't go anyplace nope
stay right around here they stay in the
yard famous with the neighbors
well yeah the neighborhoods and the
neighborhoods it's always over here
yeah yeah although i don't think anybody
lives at that house over there i will
say
i came back from my hike a couple days
ago and i
saw two old dudes like that looked like
i think they were doing an inspection
yeah so maybe somebody's buying it go
make a drink
go make a drink yeah we're gonna start
here in a minute
well like i said i'm still coming in
yeah i'm not really sure like where it
cut off
at i think i noticed because
yeah well i was talking about the first
suspect like i said we got a lot of
these get through
i'm not talking about all of them
because like i said there's [ __ ] a
thousand
right that would take a week
but this dude kenneth christensen okay
so his brother
pretty much i guess his brother never
heard of the db cooper thing before but
in 2003 he was like watching a
documentary about it
he's like hey man that sounds like it
could be my brother who died back in
1994.
why did he think this uh you ask
so kenneth christensen who like i said
died in 1994 so even if he was d.b
cooper he's
you know he died a long time ago we're
never probably going to know about it
so this dude um he was in the army
thank you aaron e hey jenny tell us what
your shirt means
oh mantle twins fertility clinic
she made that specializing in mutant
women
yes this is a i made this and uh
it perhaps it's only funny to me but
it's uh referencing
the david cronenberg movie dead ringers
from 1988
yeah about twin gynecologists looking
for a [ __ ] mutant [ __ ]
one and one of them makes like a bunch
of crazy ass tools
because he's like all the women are like
deformed
i don't know it was very funny to me and
i just so i made this shirt for myself
because
because it amused me but that's what it
is it's a david croninberg reference
so uh so yeah so he's uh
the suspect here he enlisted in the army
in 1944
trained as a paratrooper okay um
yeah check he was deployed in 1945 war
was already over
at that time but uh he did do some
training jumps he was stationed in japan
um and then after leaving the army this
is very interesting
he actually worked for northwest orient
which was the air
the airline of the plane that d.b cooper
hijacked
check um he worked there as a mechanic
okay
in the south pacific okay uh and then
subsequently was a flight attendant
on those aircraft check uh and he was
based in seattle
again czech because that's where the
plane was going i was going from
portland to seattle
so specifically he has the requisite
skills
yeah um also uh
he was in his mid-40s at the time of the
hijacking 45 45 years old check
now some people did say he was a little
bit thinner a little bit lighter skinned
a little bit
shorter than what the flight crew said
that he looked like
um fair enough he's going to be a dude
like that not not a check
but not not much she was like five foot
eight as opposed to like five foot ten
five to eleven so it's not a huge
difference
he's not like that he's gonna be a guy
like this and there are a lot of guys
like yeah yeah
right um also a chain smoker which db
cooper was also
uh also really into the bourbon which
apparently db cooper was because he
ordered two of me who was hijacking the
[ __ ] you know
um this dude was also left-handed they
also expect
now nobody knows this for certain but
some people have speculated that d.b
cooper was probably left-handed because
the uh clip-on tie that they found that
he left in the plane for whatever reason
the tie clip on it was put on from
a side that would suggest that the
wearer was left-handed that he had put
it on
the left hand and you know meaning that
he was probably left-handed so this dude
was left-handed also
um so basically i think
from what i could determine that they
showed photos of this dude and like i
said he died a long time ago they showed
photos of this dude to
the two flight attendants who had spent
the most time with
davy cooper and they said you know we're
not entirely sure but he does look
more like uh what we remember seeing
than some of the other photos that we've
been shown
so take a take of that we will it could
be this dude i don't know but like i
said he died in 1984.
um now one thing that uh again like made
people suspicious about him was that
the story went that he had purchased a
house
in cash a few months after the hijacking
now he died of cancer in 1994 as i uh
mentioned before and reportedly told his
brother on his deathbed
there's something you should know but i
cannot tell you
which how [ __ ] how [ __ ]
anticlimactic would that be you're on
your [ __ ] death bed you're dying of
cancer
you bring your family members in just
like i have something really important
to tell you
but i can't tell you what it is then you
die and everybody's like
what what was it it might have been some
[ __ ] i kind of feel like
that was the guy that was the same guy
yeah it's the same guy
so now you know what now when i'm on my
deathbed i'm totally gonna do that just
to [ __ ] but i don't have any secrets or
anything like that but
i'm i'm totally gonna do that just like
so everyone just like spend the rest of
their life like wondering what the [ __ ]
i was gonna they've had
they've had i'm the zodiac killer
they've had some dudes who were kind of
in the position to know some [ __ ]
evidently okay there's no proof of this
say on their death beds
that yes ufos are real you know what i
mean
i i have to say i don't put a lot of
stock in deathbed confessions
because one you're gonna have like some
joke
some jokers like me yeah make it up that
want one last joke before they go out
and just like i'm just gonna tell people
listen they're gonna be like talking
about this forever
and i'm just like i don't even have
anything to say whatever so it's like to
do that
and also i feel like when you're dying
maybe
maybe you're not entirely in your right
mind
no not always might be trying to
entertain people you know like see
that's what i'm kind of getting because
i
i kind of feel like and i kind of feel
like maybe now this dude does have
a lot of kind of check marks there in
what the whole like db cooper thing was
but like i said i don't put a lot of
stock in depth i can actually go ahead
and say that that when my dad was dying
he didn't die but when he was
dying [ __ ] thought the doctor
put turkey necks in his
in his [ __ ] heart exactly the kind of
[ __ ] i'm talking about
and he had me almost believe in it it's
like no
that's exactly the case that i'm talking
about i saw him
i saw him he saw that somebody put
turkey
and i went no no no no that was glenda
that came in here he gave me good
no i saw him he said i don't believe
they're dead that's your prerogative
yeah that's what i'm saying i just feel
like if you're dying or you're
undergoing some really like traumatic
emotions
um you might not be reading things in
the most
um objective way that's all i'm saying
tt
zach sent me a video a small black dude
in a wheelchair talking
and he did he says dude that sounds just
like the way you do your dad's voice
and i said no just all southerners from
that from our area we all speak ebonics
well they all kind of sound like that
because they all have like emphysema
yeah because my brain they also are the
same
my granddad sounded a little bit like
that too because he he
for real emphysema he had an oxygen tank
and everything
because he smoked for 40 years
you know what i mean so so yeah so
another thing that a lot of people kind
of like uh
looked at was that well he bought a
house with cash and it's like he had all
this money
and then when they uh after he died they
lose his bank accounts and there was
like
uh 200 grand in there right now
this seemed like real suspicious but
later investigation showed that he had
sold a bunch of land like before he died
and that kind of accounted for all the
money
and also he hadn't actually bought the
house in cash he had a mortgage on it
like a normal person
and had taken it was paid off but it
taken him 17 years to pay off so
you know so that so that's kind of like
nada's thing but
you know there were some other things
maybe suggesting but like i said
there's so many things so many suspects
in this
that have [ __ ] that could be db cooper
that it's like they're never gonna find
out who this [ __ ] dude is
t you forgot alabama alabama too
what about oh yeah oh she said that
louisiana mississippi oh yeah
tennessee black and white people all
sound the same yeah but you've got
alabama
and then panhandle panhandle of florida
same thing that's pretty much alabama
south yeah
i mean you can't eat florida
it takes an expert to be able to
understand you can tell them apart
florida's a weird state because the
panhandle
is basically like alabama yeah central
florida
is strange because it has like some big
cities but it also has some like real
rednecky
rural [ __ ] and then south florida and
then south florida is basically like old
people
yeah and cuba yeah south florida
is spanish empire it's yeah it's very
spanish
it's a great state i love i love florida
and miami
but yeah yeah he spoiled but i lived
here my whole life moving here after
living in brazil
and [ __ ] mississippi and louisiana
and [ __ ] california and [ __ ]
i love florida florida's got a mixture
it reminds me of california
back in the 70s like it's like southern
california in the 70s and the early 80s
it's like that
not quite as built up but the vibe
you know a lot of cool people in music
and a lot of scenes there's cool clubs
it's got a mixture of kind of
countrified people it's got sexy people
from other [ __ ] states
people from new york vacation in here
all the time or they're moving here
because they're sick of new york you
kind of get people from everywhere
yeah it's kind of like a weird well
that's what's florida doesn't really
have its own identity because it's just
kind of like a package for everything
[ __ ] from other then you go to tampa
it's called the i-4 corridor orlando
tampa miami
well no miami's way down south yes i-4
corridor is
tampa orlando i know that david just
said
orlando tampa daytona these areas they
have a las vegas kind of feel to them in
a certain way but yeah or a [ __ ]
amusement park kind of feel to them
they're they're they're fun
place yeah i mean all the porn comes
from of course it's going to be good
yeah they do make it yeah as well they
do make a lot of porn yeah yeah
probably cheaper to make it here than
california yeah california's [ __ ]
southern california and hollywood that's
that's over it's all here
no there's no foreign made in california
it's all made here well like i said
cheetah here probably
yeah all right so where was i uh
tila says i really like key west yeah
like a lot of you like really really
like key west it's really cool down
there
um i you know what i don't think i've
ever been to key west even though i've
lived in florida my whole life
it's far i mean miami
i don't think people realize how big
florida is i grew up in daytona beach
miami is five hours
away five hours yeah i've been there a
few times
i've been to fort lauderdale i've been
to miami and [ __ ] like that never been
to the everglades even though i'd like
to
never been to key west because that's
like [ __ ] seven eight hours away even
though it's the same state
and i've been all over you know i lived
in boston for [ __ ] five years too
and [ __ ] used to go to new york all
the time just you guys listen
[ __ ] i've been up to yankee
yankeeville too i had a [ __ ] great
time and great clubs especially
during the 90s during the mid to late
90s i liked it
um would i take it over florida no [ __ ]
no
florida i take florida over boston
boston
a lot of [ __ ] in boston a lot of
[ __ ] here though
yeah it's different though it's
different different kind of it's a very
difficult
very different i don't know like i said
i guess because i grew up here and i
grew up in kind of a rednecky area of
here
i'm so i'm kind of they're money
grubbing a lot there they're not as laid
back they're very [ __ ] uptight up in
boston they got certain [ __ ] but it
depends on where you go
the hood of boston yeah i liked it i
didn't like [ __ ] cambridge that much
somerville was a little bit better
just depends on who you're hanging out
with i was hanging out with goth people
the old school i liked them the new the
younger ones who were my age i didn't
like them as much
they were [ __ ] uptight well it's just
kind of like anywhere and the thing is
if you're in a subculture that is
established
as the goth subculture you can probably
live anywhere and as long as you found
some people that were
into the same [ __ ] as you would probably
i liked new yorkers a lot more than
bostonians i haven't thought bernie like
i've been
these are very cool i've never lived
there but i've been there a bunch of
times
um and honestly i kind of like
the cool thing about new york in general
i'm generalizing but the cool thing
about new yorkers is that they seem like
[ __ ] but they're really not as good
they're just very straightforward
they're in your face they're honest you
know what it is
yeah and i like that that's not a
bostonian a bostonian is a [ __ ]
backstabber
[ __ ] intrigue cork palace intrigue
they're like not all of them but a lot
of them you know what i mean
uh but no every time i went to new york
i had a [ __ ] great time i didn't see
it
in new york i love it there new yorkers
are not cowards
they'll they're open well if they don't
like you they will tell you right to
your face yes
it's very honest which i like that i
like and if they do like you know where
you stand right
and if they like you then they like you
not boston boston they pretend like they
like you but they [ __ ] hate you yeah
well i kind of feel like that's kind of
a thing in the south too
yeah i mean at least that yeah no it's
not
no i know both places it's not as bad
it's not as bad
i don't know there's there's kind of a
weird southerner no people in boston
will [ __ ] try to destroy you
all right they would try and [ __ ] but
i'm telling you i mean
but like i said i mean i think of all
the places i've ever been
i don't know new york and london i think
we're my favorite places i like new york
new york sorry
it's just not worth the money it's
expensive
um if it wasn't so expensive i would
probably live it's a little dirty but i
don't really care about that
you can't do the [ __ ] i like to do like
there's no motorcycle riding you can't
shoot guns you can't [ __ ] [ __ ] up
we'll see i don't care about that so
it's you know i i like you know what i
liked about new york everything was in
[ __ ] walking distance i didn't have
to have a car
you could just walk out your place and
you could just
walk to [ __ ] i liked that i don't think
that
i i you know we're talking about modern
new york that was 90s and 2000s and
2010s
it's probably not the way it is now and
but really if i were to do the new york
thing it was probably much better in the
late 70s and the 80s
probably when it was scuzzy yeah when it
was scuzzy when it was all covered with
wraps yeah i probably would have really
liked rats and hookers
i did see one oh i did see one rat when
i was in new york i was very excited
yeah because i was like i got to see a
rat when i look he's going on about t
it did like kind of run t man you got to
see
you got to see the island with my boy
in it yeah that's a very florida movie
it is kind of uh t that says top places
people are moving or arizona florida and
texas texas just moved down as well
because the reason we're about that
[ __ ] race texas is [ __ ]
texas is still cool too texas is going
to be the future well like i said
depends on where you go and
honestly if if i could live anywhere i
don't
i'm not a big fan of humidity and i'm
not a big fan of heat
because i grew up in it i don't really
like it i'd rather move somewhere where
it was like
milder and where there were actually
winters i would actually like to have
an actual winter don't be stan i guess
for a long time boston and is now moving
to miami permanently florida allure
finally because she comes and visits us
yeah [ __ ] florida's great and and i
know where sophie lives
sophie and i have friends in common kind
of friends and family
oh [ __ ] damn it's [ __ ] locked up
again
what the hell is wrong
yeah i kind of